[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW JACKSON: All
right, hi everyone.
Thanks for joining me, hope
you all are having a good week.
This is going to be a
talk about Minigo, which
is kind of the story of a
20% project that has gotten
a little out of control.
Goodness, there's a
lot of you out there.
So thanks all for coming.
So let's start I guess with the
question of what is a Minigo.
And Minigo go is a open-source
independent implementation
of the AlphaGo Zero algorithm.
So can I get a quick show
of hands of everybody
who's heard of AlphaGo?
That is a lot of
hands, that's great.
So the AlphaGo Zero algorithm
was published in "Nature."
It's the first Go AI to
beat a professional human.
And so this talk, we're going
to cover what is Minigo.
What is Go itself.
A quick little introduction to
machine learning because this
is cloud convention--
I don't want to assume that--
we're going to just sort of
a whirlwind tour of machine
learning and how it
applies to Minigo.
But what we're really
here to talk about
is how we were able to bring
this to scale on the Google
Cloud platform.
And then I'm going to do a
demo and talk a little bit
about the things that we
learned and, hopefully, this
will be useful.
So to start, what is Minigo?
Where can you find it?
It's GitHub, you can
check it out there.
It's under TensorFlow.
github.com-- or there, I guess.
github.com/tensorflow/minigo.
Feel free to check it
out, simple request.
Again, this is not an
official Google project.
I need to emphasize right
here at the beginning
that Minigo is not AlphaGo.
We're not affiliated
with DeepMind.
We're not associate
with DeepMind,
and I've coded this entirely
from just their published work.
I don't have access
to their source code,
and I haven't used their
source code to verify it.
So why did I do this at all if
DeepMind has created AlphaGo?
Why did I need to make Minigo?
Well, for starters,
I'm going to Go player.
In addition to being a
software engineer at Google,
I also volunteer for the
American Go Association, where
I serve on the
board of directors
and have worked for American Go
for almost a dozen years now.
I've been playing Go for a
substantial portion of my life,
and I love it.
And AlphaGo is amazing.
Imagine if you're a Go player
and an alien intelligence
has been created, and it
happens to speak your language.
And that's Go players-- we were
really excited about AlphaGo,
but, of course, AlphaGo retired.
So I felt like maybe
I should take a shot
at trying to create this.
So there's a lot of things
that I think that as Go players
we can do and
learn from AlphaGo.
And so there's sort of a
rich vein here to explore
and to mine.
So our goals for Minigo were
to reproduce the results
and provide a clear legible
example of the program.
If you do check it out on
GitHub, and I hope that you do.
It's only about 2,000
lines of Python,
which is pretty cool for a
world-changing algorithm.
I hope also that this can
showcase and demonstrate
what the power of
Google Cloud can do.
Because this was
basically a couple
of engineers in their 20%
time, in their spare time
trying to implement this.
And the only way that we were
going to be able to do that
was by using the longest
lever arm we can find.
And so leverage is a
verb, it kind of means
a different thing.
But quite literally
here I mean it
as a force multiplier for what
it is a very small software
engineering team.
So where did Minigo come from?
So AlphaGo and DeepMind has
been described in three papers.
The first paper
describes AlphaGo,
and that is the "Mastering the
Game of Go with Deep Neural
Networks and Tree Search."
It was published in "Nature."
And my friend, Brian
Lee, wrote something
called MuGo or
MicroGo, which was
an implementation of that
first version of the paper.
He had sort of a skeleton
implementation of it.
It implemented one half of the
network but not the other half
and was sort of like
a proof of concept.
So after AlphaGo,
their second paper
was called "AlphaGo Zero."
And AlphaGo Zero
describes an algorithm
that started from
nothing, from random noise
and then went on to teach
itself how to play go.
So mixing in AlphaGo
Zero's paper plus my friend
Brian's implementation
of MuGo, we get Minigo.
And if you're curious
about why Minigo's logo is
a happy looking robot
falling off of a ladder,
all will become clear.
I will explain why
he looks completely
at ease with the situation where
he's falling off of a ladder.
All right, so let's talk
about what the game of Go is.
How many people have played Go?
Anybody here-- wow
that's a lot people.
How many people like to play Go?
Yes, that's exactly
what I like to hear.
I love Go.
I've been playing
Go for a long time.
I really like it,
so we're going to do
a quick demo of Go what is.
This is what it looks
like at the beginning.
People take turns
putting stones down
on the board trying
to surround territory.
When we talk about capturing,
capturing looks like this.
When stones are
completely surrounded,
they get taken off the board.
That also works on
larger chains of stones,
so you can see that groups
that are connected orthogonally
share their fate, where they
will hang or stand together
as it were.
The winner is decided by--
as you try to divide
up the board, whoever
has more territory wins.
That's it.
So it's like you're
drawing up lines on a map,
you're carving up--
I get this, you get that.
You can see on the right diagram
there that white has surrounded
all the triangled points
and black has surrounded
all of the squared points.
This means that Go is not really
a sort of absolutist game,
where you have to
capture the enemy king
or completely destroy
the enemy army.
It's more like you're
negotiating an agreement,
where you just want to
get a little bit more
than the other person.
And this is an example of what
the whole game might look like.
So this is Minigo in action.
You can see it
sketching out territory,
starting in the corners.
And this pattern that you
see happening right there,
that is called a ladder.
Ladders are an interesting
example of why Go is hard.
So this is a fairly
straight forward pattern.
You can see it develop again.
It's a really obvious pattern.
It's a pattern that toddlers
can probably follow and predict,
but it's an example where
Go has a very long horizon
effect, where the
result of that ladder
could decide the
outcome of the game.
And it may require looking
80 to 90 moves ahead.
And so why is that hard?
So a ladder is
this great example
of a game where you have--
where even with a
branching factor of only
looking at two moves
for each of those cases,
you're already looking
at or 2 to the 80th--
excuse me-- possible positions.
So that very high
branching factor
makes things really difficult.
The games are really long.
The end condition is
really hard to describe.
So with Go, you want--
with chess, when the king
is captured or checkmated,
the game is over.
And everybody can see and
agree this game has ended.
With Go the game
is only over when
both players agree that
there's nothing left
on the board worth contesting.
This is pretty
difficult if you're
trying to teach a computer
how the game is over.
In fact, just scoring
the board, just knowing
that it is time to score the
board is a really hard problem.
And then lastly, and this is
possibly the most important
part, is that it's
really hard in Go
to determine who's winning
in the middle of the game.
This is one of the--
so this problem, who's
winning, who's going to win--
one of the hardest
problems we have.
Dealing with the branching
factor, that there's so many
possible moves at every point,
one of the really difficult
problems that we need to solve.
And so let's take a
step back, and let's
talk about how we're
going to approach
this with machine learning.
So this is five slides
about machine learning.
Obviously, this is not an
exhaustive explanation.
I should mention
also-- this is probably
a good time-- none of us
have PhDs on the Minigo team.
So there's probably
people in this audience
who understand this better
than I do, but bear with me.
I hope that this will be
enlightening for folks
who have maybe not done any
machine learning before at all.
So real quick-- inference
for neural networks.
So the basic idea is we're
going to put in an input
and get out an output, and
that thing in the middle
is the model that we talk about.
We don't really want
to worry too much
about what it is, except
for we need to know
a couple of things about it.
The first is that
it's a bunch of math
that is differentiable or
close enough to differentiable.
And the second is that
it's really slow--
like slow on the order of
milliseconds to evaluate.
And why does that matter
that it takes milliseconds?
It seems pretty fast.
Well, because you maybe need
to do thousands of those
before you can decide on
a move that you can play.
So we're going to consider
neural networks for inference,
inference meaning
this forward path,
where we start at our input
and we get out our decision.
That's what inference is, it's
also called a forward pass.
And we need to know that it's
slow and it's differentiable.
All right, so how do
we create that model,
that thing in the middle?
Well, what we're going to do is
we're going to try and quantify
the error, where we have
inputs that we know and outputs
that we should have gotten.
And we're going to take a look
at the difference between those
and try and change the model,
which is differentiable,
so we know which
direction we need
to push the different
values in that model
to make the error smaller.
So that's, basically,
machine learning
in a nutshell-- at least, the
stochastic gradient descent
form of machine learning.
But yeah, it's a pile
of linear algebra,
and we're going to
try to tweak it.
And we can repeat this
process where we try
and make the error slightly
smaller until we run out
of data.
That function, that
model in the middle
could be a function of many,
many millions of variables.
So we're, essentially,
trying to minimize the loss
of million variable functions.
And that's pretty
complicated, but luckily,
there are pretty
good abstractions
for doing all this stuff.
So let's keep going.
So what does inference
for Minigo, and how are we
going to use that to
solve this problem?
So inference for Minigo, in
this case, means two questions.
What moves should we play, who
do we think is going to win?
So given that board that you see
on the left, that's our input,
and we're going to ask
Minigo go for a probability
distribution of where it thinks
the next move is going to be.
And we're also going to ask
it for a number that expresses
who it thinks is going to win.
So Minigo uses negative 1
for if white is going to win,
and positive 1 if
black is going to win.
Zero says way too close to
call-- perfectly balanced--
and anywhere in there
from negative 1 to 1
is it quantifying who it
thinks is going to win.
So given those two
outputs, what is
the move that we think
is going to be played,
who do we think is
going to win, we
do something called
Monte Carlo tree search.
My friend Brian Lee, who
I mentioned wrote MuGo,
did a great talk at Pycon 2018
called "A Deep Dive into Monte
Carlo Tree Search" with code.
Also our code is on GitHub,
the Monte Carlo tree
search is really great,
super easy to read,
highly recommended.
So that deep dive into Monte
Carlo tree search is great.
So by doing this self-play
with Monte Carlo tree search,
we're able to
quantify our error.
So we asked Minigo for what
move to play and who was ahead.
And now, we can define
our error as the sum
of the difference between
the original estimate
for what move to play and
the moves that were actually
explored by tree search.
So we use that
estimate of who's going
to win to decide whether we
continue to explore that move.
So we'll look at
this move, then we'll
look at the next most
likely one under it.
And if it's better
or worse, maybe, we
won't explore that parent move.
Does that make sense,
kind of, maybe?
Can we can we just
sort of acknowledge
that this could
happen, and we can
dig into the details
at some later point.
All right, so that's Monte
Carlo tree search-- which move
and who's ahead.
The two components-- which
move and who's ahead--
are called the
policy and the value
outputs of the neural network.
So policy is given
a board state,
where do I think the
next play is going to be?
And value is how do
I value this board.
All right, so let's
do the quick recap,
that was our fifth slide.
So this is our summary slide,
this is how I get six slides.
This is our reinforcement
learning recap--
the lightning version of
reinforcement learning--
is using our data
to make models,
using our models then
to make more data,
and now we never
run out of data,
and we can keep doing
this as much as we want.
So what's the model?
The model is that pile of math
that we had in the middle.
We want to be able to measure
that loss by comparing it
with answers that we
know or with answers
that we think we know.
We train a model by
minimizing that error.
And Minigo uses the
policy and value
to do tree search to try and
refine its original estimates.
Does that make sense?
Maybe-- somebody, yeah, no?
OK, well, we're just
going to move on.
The reinforcement
learning loop--
pretty simple.
It's this nice virtuous
cycle that we can set up,
where self-play
makes better data,
and we use that in training
to make better models.
And they reinforce each other.
The problem is that--
I've made one of those
errors substantially larger,
and that's not an
accident, because the idea
is that doing tree
search involves
doing many of these
inferences or forward passes.
We want to do as
many readouts as we
need to be able to ensure that
we're improving our policy.
And that means doing maybe
hundreds or thousands
of inferences per each move.
Now, if we can
train on each move,
that means we're doing hundreds
or thousands of inferences
per training data
point that we make.
So at a minimum, we're going
to have this ratio where
we need to do hundreds to one
in terms of making inferences
versus making training steps.
Does that sort of set
up the problem here?
So in order to
train adequately, I
need to do this for
millions of games,
and I know that a game will
take on the order of minutes
even when I'm
using GPUs or TPUs.
So my question becomes,
how do I scale this?
Now, happily this is
a problem that is--
to borrow someone's phrase--
embarrassingly parallel.
Having two copies of
Minigo play each other
does not involve
any other copies
of Minigo, which means that I
can spin up as many of these
as I can, assuming I have a
good way to shard this all out
or scale this all out.
And so that brings us
to the part of the talk
that I think we're
all here for, which
is using this on Google Cloud.
So we used Kubernetes
to do this,
but we started by making the
smallest possible units of work
that we could.
So our training job was
pretty straightforward.
And we made our worker
job use Cloud storage
as a way to sort of coordinate
what we needed to do.
This worked really well.
Cloud Storage, as it turns
out, is incredibly flexible,
and you can abuse it in all
sorts of interesting ways.
We were able to use
Cloud Storage to get
the sort of tracer bullet,
while we're sort of deciding
do we need to write
a centralized server
or do these need to
talk to a server at all?
And Cloud Storage, basically,
scaled to the point
that we didn't really bother.
So it stood up
wonderfully, and we've
been able to use that
probably beyond the limits
that we certainly
thought we could.
Then what we did was we
turned this into containers.
So we used Docker
to build containers
for that self-pay worker, and
we used Kubernetes to scale this
out to thousands of nodes.
So we did this,
we could start up,
we could fetch the latest model.
We could write out our data.
We could shut down
and start up again.
And since each time, we're
fetching the latest version
of the model, we're always able
to coordinate and make sure
that we're generating new data
with the latest and best model
that we have.
So what we originally
did was we originally
wrote this on a
smaller board size.
So the original diagrams that
I showed you at the beginning
were Go being played
on a 19 by 19 board--
that is the full
size game of Go.
Go is also played
on a 9 by 9 board.
And this 9 by 9 board
is a lot simpler.
The model for that is
about 250 times faster.
So we were able
to sort of verify
correctness using that smaller
model on a smaller Go board.
And I'm using
correctness very loosely.
Because, as it turns
out, machine learning
is very good at finding
patterns in your data or--
patterns in your data that
you didn't mean to put there.
It's very good at covering up
for mistakes that you make.
So we saw something get better
on our smaller sized board that
had really glaring,
horrible bugs
that we wouldn't discover
until later but more on that.
The next thing we did-- so
after we did this and verified
our correctness on
the smaller board,
we realized that, holy
cow, the full size model
is going to be 250 times slower.
We need to add accelerators.
And so we were able to hook up
GPUs with a minimum of fuss.
We were running a cluster
of about 2,100 GPUs
units with no problem at all.
Using GPUs on
Kubernetes is fantastic.
It means we don't have
to worry about drivers.
We didn't have to
make any code changes.
What ran on our workstation
would run perfectly
on Kubernetes Engine.
And this was a
pretty great success,
but it was still a little slow.
We had some benchmark
performance numbers
that we were trying to hit.
So the numbers in
the AlphaGo paper
detailed that they were able to
perform 1,600 inferences in 0.4
seconds.
We were about 40 times
slower than that,
which is OK for a
solution that was Python,
and for our accelerators,
which were not TPUs.
But 40 times slower
meant 40 times slower.
They were able to train, play
5 million games in three days.
And if we are 40 times
slower than that,
I'm looking at this
taking three months.
So that's a little challenging.
I needed to find a way
to do this more faster.
So before we do that,
let's take a little step
and say that as I'm
setting this up on GPUs
and I'm realizing that this is
going to take months to run,
I really wanted to
find ways to verify
that everything was working.
So with containers,
it was really easy
for me to make variations
on the jobs I was running
and really try to run other
sorts of evaluation matches.
It was really easy to
use the Kubernetes Engine
API to spin up jobs
that were variants,
so I could test different
version of models--
make sure that I'm
making progress.
This was a really
important thing
that I'm going to
come back to later.
And when I say,
measuring performance,
I'm measuring
performance on my task,
which is, are my models actually
getting better at playing Go?
That's a real question.
So early on, I knew that this
was going to take three months.
At the point that Cloud TPUs
were being developed I said,
hey, this might work
really well if I could
try running this on Cloud TPUs.
And the Cloud TPU team
was pretty enthusiastic,
and they said, yes,
sure, go right ahead.
But they were so
much faster that it
meant really reevaluating
how I had originally
written my pipeline.
For reference, the 2,000
GPUs that I was using
were a few generations
old, so I'm deliberately
avoiding making any sort of
direct numerical comparison.
But suffice to say that what
was previously fine in Python
was now no longer fine
using a Cloud TPU.
There was no way
that the code was
going to be fast
enough, which meant
that if I was going to be able
to use these TPUs effectively,
I would need to seriously
rethink how this pipeline was
going to run.
When you're planning on
something taking three months,
and now you're looking
at maybe a week or two,
you have some very
different constraints
about how long you can take
to preprocess your input data,
how long you can take
to lazily push out
the results of the new models.
It's all that sort of thing.
So what we had to do was
we had to rewrite for TPUs.
This code is Monte
Carlo tree search.
This is the short pseudocode
for Monte Carlo tree search.
And I'd like to draw your
attention to that line that
says
NeuralNet.evaluate(leaf.game
state), because that is the one
that suddenly this whole thing
needed to go in parallel.
And it needed to go in parallel
a lot faster than it could.
And so this was the part--
the engine that would do
this rapidly was the part
that we needed to rewrite.
So that's what it looks like
on a single threaded version.
This is pretty close to what
the Python code actually
looks like in Minigo today.
And so rewriting it for TPUs
involved breaking this out
into a multi-threaded version.
A friend of mine volunteered
to do the C++ rewrite, and--
he's probably not going
like me telling his story.
But he was able to write
this complete multithreaded
implementation--
no problem, no bugs,
doing a full rewrite,
multithreaded code, no
bugs, no race conditions,
no problems like that.
But he had forgotten to
actually increment a loop
and was left with a brutal
bug that took days to debug.
He was like, oh, I'm so bad.
I'm like, you just
did a complete rewrite
of multithreaded code that
had no bugs the first time.
And you're going to be
hard on yourself for that.
Anyway, so this is
what it looked like.
We ended up building a container
out of our C++ port that would
spin up a Python engine, and we
would do these RPC calls when
our queue had enough nodes
in it to run them all through
the model.
And this did great--
it also meant that our C++
code no longer depended
on TensorFlow, so it didn't have
to have any trouble building
TensorFlow, which made
our builds a lot quicker,
which is pretty cool.
And once we had
this engine, now we
could change to
using deployments
on Kubernetes Engine.
Previously, when we were using
GPUs, we used the batch API.
Quick show of hands,
people who have used
Kubernetes before in this room?
Cool, that's great.
The batch API
worked really well.
With 2,000 nodes, we had
some interesting limits
around tracking completions.
And what we ended up
doing was not bothering.
We ended up writing our job as
a job where we set something
like 100,000 completions.
And what that would
actually do is
it would throw away
completions after about 1,000,
which meant that it would
just run constantly,
which was what we wanted.
The completions--
writing it as a batch API
worked really well, because that
meant that it would just always
retry.
It would handle the
retry logic for us.
That all worked really well.
But now with Cloud
TPUs, we didn't
want to pay the price of
having the containers go down
and come up again.
So we wrote them to be long
running jobs as deployments.
And this all worked really well.
We didn't need to track
completions anymore,
because we were writing
these as long running jobs.
And so this all just, basically,
worked out of the box.
One of the advantages
of Minigo is
that we were able to test this.
So Minigo is entirely public.
It's all available
on GitHub, which
meant that throughout
this entire project,
I was following
the exact same path
that external
customers would follow.
Although, I'm a
Googler, I, basically,
was going through the
exact same process
that anybody in
this room would have
if they tried to go through it.
And that was a pretty
great experience.
Honestly, I hit way fewer--
and also a lot of these
were while these products
were pre-alpha or
getting ready for alpha.
And the experience
was honestly amazing.
Cloud TPUs on Kubernetes
Engine have basically
worked out of the box.
Ditto for the GPUs, like I
said, the driver problems
were not even a thing
that I had to worry about.
So if you're thinking about
doing ML or accelerated
computing on Kubernetes
Engine, I, basically, only
have good things
to say about it.
So that's pretty great.
So let me do a quick
demo of Minigo.
I think there's a way
for me to make this play,
but I don't know what it is.
There we go.
That looks like it.
So this Minigo-- thinking about
this particular game, this
is that small size board.
I think this was actually
running in CPU only
on a laptop.
It may even have
been a Chromebook.
So this is running completely
unaccelerated on that smaller
size of Go that I was
telling you about-- oops.
And it doesn't loop,
which is unfortunate.
But you can see the
variations that it's
considering in the
upper right, what
it thinks is the
most likely move
to happen in the left side.
And this is a pretty great tool.
If you're a Go
player, you can really
dig in and see what
it's thinking about,
why, what it likes,
what it doesn't like--
pretty great.
All right, so talking
about our results--
All right, so results, OK, so
talking about the conclusions
and the lessons learned, I kind
of want to talk a little bit
about the trends
here that we've had,
which is moving from GPUs
to TPUs-- and, in this case,
these were older GPUs
to the newest TPUs--
has been eye-opening.
The ability for
us to do more work
with basically the same
amount of electricity
means that us users have
our incentives aligned
with Cloud providers to use the
newest and fastest hardware.
Basically, there's
no reason that we
want people to use the older
versions of the hardware,
because the newer
versions of the hardware
will do more work with
the same wattage, which
means that we really want you
to use the newest thing that you
can.
So as long as this
holds, there's
going to be this
pressure for us to make
our code go as fast as
possible, and this is fantastic.
In particular, when
you're doing research,
if you're trying to
dial in these solutions,
you need to be
able to experiment
as quickly as you can.
You need to be able to try
things that might have been
too expensive to try otherwise.
And so having this push to use
the best price per performance
and having the price
per performance
use the fastest thing,
not use the slower thing,
means that we can really
dial in the models
that we're trying to
build, that we can really
iterate faster on
how we're going
to test the various ideas we
have for how to develop models.
But what that
means is that means
you should plan for your
pipeline to get faster.
Again, we had originally
bracketed that this would
take us a couple of months.
And now, we're
looking at getting
it done in a week or two.
And that changed some of our
core assumptions about how long
we'd have to do a lot
of the different steps
in that pipeline, and it
seems like that's only
going to continue.
So definitely you want
to plan accordingly.
That is the Cloud Edge TPU,
which is the little UBS gum
stick on which we're going to
make Minigo, which I'm really
excited about.
In relation to this idea
that your pipeline is going
to be faster, we really
want to try and make
our models more like
cattle and less like pets.
You guys with the cattle not
pets metaphor from containers?
Some folks may be getting
the idea-- the idea
being that containers lets
you reproduce the exact build
of the software you're running.
You can say that my
server is interchangeable,
that I can get more of them.
I don't need to give it
a name, it's not special.
It's not a big deal if it
dies or goes down or breaks,
and I have to rebuild it.
In the same way, we'd like
our neural network models
to be like that as well,
where if it takes you
three months to do it, you
get kind of possessive.
Like, you really don't want
to see anything happen to it.
But if you can make a
new one in a day or two,
now, you have this freedom and
ability to experiment and try
things.
And it means that you
can keep those changes
much better isolated.
With our early runs on GPUs
that were taking months,
it was very tempting
to constantly monitor
the dashboard, try
and tweak some knobs,
try and turn some
dials here and there,
and worry and fret over it.
But it also meant that at
the end of that process,
how could I reproduce exactly
that sequence of things
that happened?
Really hard-- having
it all go faster
means that it's all a
lot more repeatable,
and that's pretty great.
Another thing that's
pretty interesting
here is that these reinforcement
learning systems really
resemble distributed systems.
So I imagine a lot of folks
here work in the cloud,
and they're familiar
with the idea
that your individually,
well-behaved systems stop
being well-behaved in tandem.
And that's pretty interesting
from a number of reasons.
I think that there's
sort of two ways
that we go about analyzing
why our systems are
doing the wrong thing.
One of them is from the code up,
where we can look at the code
and understand exactly
what will happen.
And the other way is
from the behaviors
that we see down, where we have
to think about what's happening
and generate a hypothesis.
And say, OK, if the load
balancer is doing this,
then we would expect this,
and I can test that this way.
Maybe you can't solve
that just by looking
at the load balancers
code and the servers--
you have to generate a
hypothesis and test it.
And those are two
very distinct steps.
I think it's inductive
versus deductive.
And in a very similar
way, neural networks
and developing neural networks
have the same problem,
where we can't directly
point at a line of code
for why a model makes
a decision it does.
But, instead, you
created code that
made that model,
which means more
of the top-down
type of debugging.
You still need to be able
to look at specific code
and try and figure
out what's going on.
But in this way,
the reinforcement
learning systems
really resemble a lot
of the distributed systems.
And the idea that
debugging is a process
of generating
hypotheses, figuring out
how to test the hypothesis
in isolation, verifying.
OK, well, I did this,
I expected this,
this other thing happened-- what
does that mean for my intuition
about how these
systems are working?
All right, so let's sort
of wrap things up a bit.
There's two major
parts of this--
the machine learning part and
the software engineering part.
And I'm trying to focus on this
talk mostly on the how part.
How did we get to 90 petaflops?
How did we monitor health?
How did we get the
performance that we need?
How do we make it work?
I haven't touched,
basically, any
of the machine learning parts.
Why is the network this way?
Why are these
constants like this?
Why is the network
structured like this?
Those "why" questions,
those are pretty tough,
but we can't really
answer those whys until we
have the hows nailed down.
So if you have your neural
network, your machine learning
problems that you're
trying to figure out,
the answers to these
questions, obviously, those
are going to be domain specific.
But when you say, OK, well, how
am I going to deploy and test
these applications, how am I
going to test my hypotheses,
the answer there has
been a cloud platform
that's worked fantastically.
So let's talk a little bit about
the things that did work really
well.
So I've included a little
Stackdriver dashboard
that we used.
Stackdriver was fantastic.
We could just throw
things to standard output
and regex through them
without any trouble.
I mentioned Cloud Storage also
scaling way beyond the level
that we talked.
So our early clusters were
putting out maybe 50,000 games
a day with a full size model.
With TPUs, we're putting out
over a million games a day
and still having to download
and handle them all.
And Cloud Storage has
just been a champ.
At some point, we're thinking
about doing integration
with Cloud Bigtable,
but that's still TBD.
And in the meantime, Cloud
Storage has just been--
we just abuse it.
It's really wonderful.
Kubernetes Engine and
Cloud TPUs, as I mentioned,
those basically
worked out of the box.
If you're interested
in using them,
it's a pretty great
experience-- definitely sign up,
what you need to do.
TensorBoard 1.9-- the latest
release of TensorBoard
will let you serve your
TensorBoard dashboards right
out of Cloud Storage,
which is great.
If you are trying to
use the Cloud TPUs,
the profiling tools
are easy to use.
They're useful to
dig into and find out
how you can get the most
performance out of those TPUs.
So all of these parts
of using the cloud stack
went really well.
As for those whys, I love this
quote here from Alex Ipran.
Reinforcement learning
is really hard.
He has this quote--
if it turns out random, I have
no idea if it's something I did
or if I just got unlucky.
We have some of these algorithms
in the state of the art
machine learning right now
that may be a correctly working
version with a different
random seed will not
converge on a solution, and
that's kind of astonishing.
That here's a
successful result that's
been published that only
works 30% of the time.
Obviously, AlphaGo Zero
seems to be much more robust,
but it kind of points
out the challenges
in testing these
hypotheses, and the need
to be able to iterate
and isolate and sort
of formulate hypotheses
and see if they work.
This is kind of an amazing
quote that I really
like to think about.
For me personally,
I've been following
in the footsteps
of published papers
where I know what is
possible, because DeepMind
had published their papers.
It would be much
harder for me to--
like, just trying
to imagine if I
was in their shoes, where I get
a model that turns out pretty
good, but not great.
And I say to
myself, well, can it
be better or is this the best
I can do with this approach?
There's a very big difference
between exploring the unknown
and reproducing the known.
In my case, if I
hit a ceiling, I
can compare that ceiling to
the ceiling that they described
and say, OK, well, I
clearly have a bug.
Whereas, for somebody doing new
research for the first time,
it's going to be much harder for
you to say is this the ceiling
or do I have bugs?
You really need to be able
to be diligent and controlled
and make sure that you
are able to isolate
the parts of your system and
make sure that each of them
is doing what you think.
Does that kind of makes sense?
Great, awesome.
And lastly, I kind
of want to quote
about why I'm really
excited as a Go player
that all of these things
are finally taking shape.
I started Minigo after
the AlphaGo paper
was published, which I think
was November of last year.
And since then, Facebook
has announced an open source
version.
They've just released
a model Tencent.
And other Chinese
companies have been
working on models, which they've
released with various degrees
of openness.
And it's been very
exciting to have these.
And an open source project
called Leela Zero has also
been done, where they've
been trying to crowdsource
all of the GPU compute needed.
And it's been really
excellent to have
all of these different
folks try to reproduce
the paper with varying
amounts of success.
And it's really
wonderful as a Go player
to have access to these,
essentially, oracles.
Go players like to think
of playing a game of Go
as having a conversation,
talking with someone.
We have a great proverb
that playing a game of Go
with someone is like living
with them for a year.
And in that case, we
have this new thing
that is saying new
creative ideas to us
that we haven't really
understood before.
So if you are interested
in learning more
about the game of Go,
definitely check it out online.
There's a lot more resources.
And, hopefully, it's going to
be a lot easier to learn now
that we have ways
to understand it.
We do try to hang stories
on our moves that we play.
And it's going to be a little
bit easier for us to sort of do
that and understand that as we
have better tools to dig into.
So thank you all very much.
A big thank you to the folks who
have helped donate their time
to work on Minigo.
That's Tom, Seth,
Brian, and Josh--
they all have been instrumental
in making Minigo possible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]